pour l'avocate des parties civiles ce
procès est celui de la maltraitance
animale
l'éleveur à la barre aujourd'hui n'a pas
su n'a pas voulu prendre soin de ses
bêtes
elles lui ont été confisqués pour éviter
le pire ce sont plus de 100 bêtes qui
sont mortes et celle que nous avons
récupéré les survivantes était dans un
état de maigreur extrême ce qu'on
appelle la cachexie n'avait plus que les
la peau sur les os et grâce à cette
saisie est bien celle ci au moins ont pu
être sauvées novembre 2010 est une
centaine de vaches sont saisis et retiré
par les services de l'état pour mauvais
traitement à un agriculteur de l'yonne
sur ce troupeau de 250 bêtes au départ
145 sont déjà mortes en un an et demi la
procédure rare et exceptionnel est alors
vécu comme une injustice par l'éleveur
son exploitation coller de grandes
difficultés économiques et lui-même de
graves problèmes familiaux et de santé
pour les syndicats agricoles au delà de
ce cas personnel ce procès illustre
aussi une certaine réalité pour en
arriver là c'est quelque part
économiquement ça va pas bien moralement
ça va pas bien socialement aussi des
grandes détresses et un grand isolement
et si calais centre et des rares
périodes depuis la saisie des bêtes
l'exploitation agricole est en
redressement judiciaire et a déposé le
bilan
pour l'avocat de l'éleveur la décision
de lui retirer son troupeau est
arbitraire et infondées mais elle
fragilise encore un peu plus son client
d'un point de vue économique c'est de
plus en plus difficile
là il ya malheureusement beaucoup
d'agriculteurs en difficulté je vous
rappelle qu'il ya je crois un suicide
tous les deux jours donc c'est quand
même significatif de l'état de
l'agriculture
les parties civiles on demandait le
retrait définitif du cheptel et que
l'éleveur ne puisse plus jamais exercer
en plus d'une amende et de dommages et
intérêts l'avocat de l'agriculteur a
quant à lui plaidé la relaxe et que le
troupeau d'une centaine de vaches lui
soient restitués